it's continuing to build last week or
maybe it was the week before I told you
robert muller might want to talk to
president Donald Trump in the Trump
Russia investigation yesterday I told
you yes Moeller definitely wants to talk
to Trump and he is now in touch with
Donald Trump's legal team to figure out
sort of the particulars and now Donald
Trump says he quote would love to talk
to robert muller even maybe surprisingly
under oath he appeared impromptu
yesterday at a press briefing he was
asked about this possible interview with
robert molars Trump Russia investigation
and here's what he had to say I'm
looking forward to it actually you want
to do there's been no collusion
whatsoever
there's no obstruction whatsoever and
I'm looking forward to it I do worry
when I look at all of the things that
you people don't report at that right
with what's happening if you take a look
at you know the five months worth of
missing texts that's a lot of missing
texts and as I said yesterday that's
prime time so you just want to look at
that and say what's going on
you do look at certain texts where they
talk about insurance policies or
insurance where they say the kinds of
things they're saying you gotta be
concerned but I would love to do that
and I'd like to do it as soon as
possible of to do it and as soon as
possible and what about under oath he
would do under oath as well take a
listen to this I have to say you
subjected my lawyers and all of that but
I would love to do it you mean like
Hillary Jenner under who said oh you
said it used to say you say a lot did
Hillary do it under oath do you not have
an idea you really not have an idea I'll
give you an idea she didn't do it under
oath
I would do it and you know she didn't do
it under us right if you didn't do it if
you didn't know about Hillary then
you're not surprised much of oh I would
do it under Oakland absolutely no I
would a total chaos in the room clearly
as you can tell straight talker Donald
Trump right he'll do it he would love to
do it and he'll do it under oath
except immediately after this took place
Trump's attorney Ty Cobb named after a
famous baseball player started walking
it back none of it is happening
according to Ty Cobb Ty Cobb said that
Trump is ready to meet with them that he
was speaking hurriedly and that the
parameters are actually going to be
guided by Trump's legal team not by what
Trump says to reporters off-the-cuff at
one of these impromptu press briefings
so basically know under oath period if
Ty Cobb or any other attorney has a say
and maybe not even a full in-person
interview there are sort of a couple
things to keep in mind you right first
of all when the president's lawyer is
regularly and immediately saying yeah
that thing the president just said
that's not actually true we're not going
to be doing what the president just said
that's basically saying the president
has no idea what he's talking about when
he talks about things as specifically as
I would love to speak to Muller and I
would do it under oath I guess he didn't
mean that at all and that's concerning
because whenever we hear anything from
Trump we now need to check I guess with
either Trump's lawyer or Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the press secretary or someone
else to be told
Trump did mean what he said or Trump
didn't mean what he said so that's
number one
secondly even if this hadn't been walked
back immediately by Trump's lawyer Ty
Cobb Trump saying I would love to
testify under oath still has no actual
bearing on whether Trump will testify
under oath because Trump says stuff all
the time it's a sort of a silly example
but remember when Trump promised that
really specifically we are going to do a
press conference this was back during
the campaign to explain Melania Trump
working illegally in the United
when she first came here he didn't say
at some point we will say more about it
he said we're going to do a press event
and we will tell you exactly what went
on with melania and these allegations
that she was in the u.s. working
illegally just never happened right and
Trump gets the benefit from promising
the thing without ever actually doing
the thing if it never happens well there
will have been some reason right but
Trump was willing here he says I would
love to speak to Muller and I would do
it under oath but he can always say my
lawyers actually weren't able to set my
lawyers told me not to do it or I was
willing to do it if Moeller gave me the
questions ahead of time and he wasn't
willing to do that Trump says it and
gets the benefit and if it doesn't
happen the trumpets aren't gonna hold
him to it anyway yeah that's that's his
way of getting it both ways I guess but
you could always just fire your lawyers
or go against their wishes if you wanted
to it's question of you know who hires
whom right if Trump really was
determined that the right thing and the
moral thing and the best thing was to
testify rather to be interviewed by
robert muller and to do it under oath of
course ultimately the buck stops with
Trump as he has made very clear since he
became president of the United States
that everything stops with him another
example is the tax returns right he'll
release the tax returns if X happens or
if Y happens and he never did and he
never really planned to but he got a lot
of the benefit out of it just from
saying he would because his followers
would hear Trump say look he's got
nothing to hide he says as soon as X or
Y happens he'll release the tax returns
he would never say that if he had
something to hide and of course saying
you're going to do something doesn't
mean you're actually going to do
something now I think the most likely
scenario with this Moeller interview I
don't know your sense of it Pat but I
think the most likely scenario is they
agree to not under oath with Trump's
attorney or attorneys sitting there with
him and a lot of I would have to follow
up with you in writing about that to try
to get Trump not in a situation where
he's going to self-incriminate which is
a major risk if your Trump's lawyer very
favorable conditions and I'm guessing
that you can get that if you're the
I would think so they're probably gonna
ask for the questions ahead of time
there they will definitely ask and I
hope that they wouldn't get them right I
mean did this it's sort of imperative
that you not give Trump the questions
ahead of time this is a criminal
investigation after all and the last
thing you want is really specifically
thought-out responses but again they
will use the I don't recall but I'd be
glad to follow up in writing things so
that later they can just huddle and
figure out the least incriminating way
to answer a lot of these questions
timeline we're still being told two to
three weeks presumably before whatever
version of this interview is agreed upon
by Trump's lawyers and Muller's team
takes place I'm looking forward to it I
don't know that it's going to be the
fireworks that we might imagine it to be
but once you get to the president that
this is a big deal this is no small
thing oh yeah I don't know if it'll be
fireworks because Muller runs a very
tight ship yes obviously this thing
isn't gonna be televised too though so
maybe we'll see some leaks about what
happened in that interview but I'm not
expecting fireworks out of it I read
something about Kushner is hesitating
about being interviewed because of the
leak of that Fusion GPS transcript
I guess he's saying he didn't like how
that ended up being released just
unilaterally by Dianne Feinstein and
that's part of why he now I guess is
refusing to go in any way it's all
spiraling and we will continue to follow
it and hopefully Trump is interviewed in
some format or another sooner than later
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership